( intro music )
My laboratory
gets in and explores
and we really
explore a world
that's invisible
to the naked eye.
And so, if we take a look at
these scanning electron
microscopy images
you'll get a closer view.
So, we are looking in now,
at over 3000-times zoomed
and you can see our
inner intestines
there are all
of these cells
that are-- turns out
aren't our own cells
but are actually
microbial cells.
Largely bacteria but also
viruses and fungi and protozoa
that inhabit our bodies.
And the same can be said about
virtually every exposed
environmental site on our bodies
and so, here is a
picture of the mouth
where you see not
really our own cells
but other microbial cells.
And so, I think that you can
see from these pictures that
these are actually
really, really like habitats
that are within our
own body world.
And it turns out that they are
not passive members either.
They form communities
and they interact
and they divide and replicate
and they even wage wars
against each other.
These microbes outnumber at
our own human eukaryotic
cells ten-to-one.
And this actually means not
ten-times amounts of genes
but it turns out that for
every human gene that we have
there are over 360
bacterial genes.
So, they outnumber our
own human genomes.
And we are just starting to
learn about what they can do
and how we've co-evolved
with these microbes
to influence our own
biological function.
These microbes
are very diverse.
So there are over 10,000 unique
species that inhabit us.
And they outnumber greatly all
of the disease causing microbes
or pathogens that we are used
to studying in the laboratory.
And so, my lab in
particular is interested in
how these microbes aside
from affecting digestion
and immunity and metabolism,
can influence the brain
and behavior.
So, in terms of
brain and behavior
one thing that's really
important to note is that
the brain itself is a
very complex organ.
But adding on to that another
whole layer of complexity
is that the brain doesn't
act in isolation.
It responds to the
needs and experiences
of all our other body sites.
And so, the microbiota, as you
know, as an important organ
turns out to feed into
brain and behavior as well.
Many, many conditions now
are known to be linked
to changes in the
communities of microbes
that inhabit our bodies.
And some of these,
also include
neurological disorders.
The frontier of this is to see
whether we could use bacteria
to really hack into
brain function
a relatively inaccessible area.
And so, we really need
to study in these--
in these diseases whether
we can use microbes
to cause or correct diseases.
The implications are huge,
because microbes we know
are relatively accessible by us.
We know how to engineer
them and modify them
and eradicate them
if we need to.
And in our bodies they
colonize persistently.
And the idea is can
we use these microbes
to treat neurological disorders
in a relatively non-invasive way
to provide long lasting impacts
and with regulatory controls
that we build in and design in
on these microbes
when we modify them.
Thank you very much.
( applause )